ces deux manières de défendre la terre
mais apparemment l'écologie son assiette
qui les représentait mais parce que marc
lemaire le maire de bordeaux même par
notre invité c'est pas aujourd'hui j'en
passe et des sapins ça fait plus d'un
siècle qu'on en fait poussé dans des
parcelles qui sont prévus à cet effet
alors des sapins d'un homme trois ans 5
ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans les plus
grandes
d'accord ils sont faits pour ça pour
pouvoir donner du bonheur chaque année à
tout le monde
et oui on les élève pour ça pour donner
ce bonheur aux gens alors je trouve que
dans une période qui est quand même
assez anxiogène par des forêts pour le
papier pour les livres d'ailleurs bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr
enfin dans tout la filature le papier ça
va bien sûr mais a aujourd'hui ça ne
gêne en rien dans l'écologie par contre
monsieur je vais vous dire rendez la
terre aux agriculteurs et après on verra
votre ciel et la terre c'est vous qui
l'avez voulu mais dans tous les produits
chimiques
si on ne fait pas pousser du blé un
service human pour lui père monsieur
vous aidera ces messieurs quand même un
jour est le monsieur je vous ai pas
couper la parole je vous ai écouté
jusqu'à maintenant vous me la coupe est
promptement comme ça je verrai s'il vous
plaît de prendre le temps de m'écouter
vous le soulignez la terre a aujourd'hui
c'est vous qui l'avait ruiné tout votre
système d'aggro consommation la terre a
aujourd'hui allait ruiner
à cause de quoi les lobbyings c'est tout
laisser respirer la terre un an sans
rien y faire et replanter quelque chose
dessus ça pousse monsieur sur vos
chances depuis l'échangé
surtout les chants du monde et de la
terre attendez un angle et la terre
reprend ses droits
par contre vos produits on n'en veut
plus se faire en veut plus moi moi moi
ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est j'ai
l'impression que vous considérez les
agriculteurs comme des adversaires
idéologiques envers trois cas là parce
que pas du tout les français sont
extrêmement attachés au tour de france
au sapin noël et aux agriculteurs donc
là on lui a déjà perdu cinq cent mille
voix pour l'ancienne
moi je fais pas le champagne mais oui
bah ça ne fait pas alors c'est quoi une
tradition nous ne fait pas campagne
c'est peut-être la tradition monsieur ne
nous parlent d'une tradition une
tradition qui a 70 ans fait de mettre
des pesticides et des engrais dans le
sol pour faire pousser
c'est quoi une tradition qui a 70 ans
c'est peut-être juste une mauvaise
habitude peut-être ses clients donné
c'est parce que mon âge soyez polis
voulait d'abord merci les engrais azotés
sont responsables du changement
climatique
les pesticides sont responsables de
l'effondrement actuel de la biodiversité
il est temps de changer de modèle et
justement avec le sapin on peut il
parvenir je te par exemple le sapin au
lieu de l'incinérer comme il est homme
s'est massivement fait pour la plupart
des sapins jetables on pourrait les
broyer et s'en servir pour les champs
pour faire un paillage divers qui
pourraient permettre de protéger les
champs alors déjà le sapin ne s'en
servent pas de paille à gillet
putrescibles et tuent les plantes donc
des gens ne fait pas de paillage avec du
sa peine on peut utiliser du chêne
monsieur n'utilise d'utilisation vous
quelqu'un qui se bat il fallait pas
vraiment métier c'est quelqu'un qui se
battrait contre la torture en demandant
aux gens de ne pas écraser des playmobil
c'est absurde si vous voulez eric a dit
quelque chose tout à l'heure de très
juste
vous savez souvent vos propos vos
combats sont sans doute très juste mais
si vous voulez ridiculiser vous même
avant qu'on puisse avoir un accès
intelligible au débat vous tirer une
balle dans le pied parce que avoir des
propositions radicales ce serait par
exemple d'interdire tous les sapins dans
une ville sauf un seul celui qui serait
sur la place principale à là on aurait
quelque chose de radical qui pourrait
enfin choqués on pourrait vraiment se
battre intelligemment mais là vous nous
obliger à nous battre contre une chose
stupide vous nous forcez des don
quichotte avec des cure dents
merci
[Applaudissements]